and we begin this morning with reports
of charges in the case involving
Russia's alleged interference in last
year's presidential election first
reported by CNN and later confirmed by
Reuters and The Wall Street Journal the
first indictment from special counsel
robert muller was approved by a federal
grand jury and sealed by a federal judge
but it looks like we may have to wait a
few days to get all the details
Errol Barnett is at the White House Erol
good morning good morning president
Trump has long described special counsel
mullahs russia probe as a witch-hunt and
a hoax but the news now that the first
indictments are ready to be charged
calls into question president Trump's
tweet from Friday morning in which he
claimed quote it is now commonly agreed
there was no collusion between Russia
and Trump however that is not yet the
definitive conclusion of the special
counsels investigation in fact according
to reports a federal grand jury has
approved charges stemming from the probe
on Friday special counsel Robert Muller
of course is investigating Russian
collusion during last year's election
between elements of President Trump's
campaign and the Kremlin but Muller is
also tasked with looking into any
matters that arise from the
investigation that could include for
example financial crimes a federal judge
has sealed this indictment so it's
unclear what these charges are or who
they are specifically against we do know
that former Trump campaign Chairman Paul
Manafort has been a focus for Muller
paying specific attention to his
financial links and lobbying efforts for
a pro-russian political party in Ukraine
the president's former national security
adviser Michael Flynn has also been
under the microscope for money he
received from Turkish and Russian
interests sources are also quoted as
saying any individual or individuals
charged as it relates to this indictment
could be taken into custody as soon as
Monday
Anthony Errol Barnett at the White House
thanks Errol